stell dir vor du wirst aus dem schlaf
gerissen
[Applaus]
heerscharen von aliens überfallen
unseren planeten
[Applaus]
sie sind uns körperlich geistig und
technologisch weit überlegen wir müssen
für sie schuften und sie nutzen uns für
medizinische versuche manche von uns
leben sie auch mit ihnen herum zu teilen
und zu knuddeln
aber nicht alle menschen haben das glück
dass haustiere eines aliens zu sein
sie verspeisen uns menschen genüsslich
am liebsten zartes kinder fleisch
den frauen gucken sie die milch ab und
machen daraus leckere drinks millionen
von menschen werden eingesperrt und
gemästet und anschließend geschlachtet
[Musik]
völlig empört rennst du zum anführer und
stellt ihn zur rede
so kann es doch nicht weitergehen
wie könnt ihr nur so grausam sein was
regst du dich so auf ich nach dir denn
nicht dasselbe profitieren
du verlierst den boden unter den füßen
hat er außerirdische nicht recht
verhalten wir uns tieren gegenüber nicht
genau so dürfen wir tieren etwas antun
was man uns nicht antun darf
[Musik]
[Applaus]